okay let's get right into audience
questions the first one
uh is about mike pence david would
replacing mike pence help
donald trump get reelected would it help
him in the polls
so it's extremely unlikely that
replacing pence would help trump
and it has the serious potential to hurt
donald trump and there's a few things
you have to understand about vp picks
vp picks um the the
the situation the risk reward with the
vice presidential pick
is asymmetrical and what i mean by that
is a bad vp
pick can hurt you much more than a good
vp
pick can help you because a good vp pick
essentially causes no drama
causes no scandals stays out of the way
is a reasonably okay debater so that in
the
not particularly uh a highly viewed vice
presidential debate
they hold their own and they essentially
just they know the talking points they
don't get hugely embarrassed you know
sarah palin
uh uh in her vp debate really didn't do
well but it still didn't
really hurt mccain palin that much i
mean it already wasn't going
particularly well for them
but on the other hand if you have a
great vp
they don't do that much for you and so
that's why the ac asymmetrical nature
to me would suggest that unless pence is
a problem for trump
it's risky to replace him and you also
have to remember
replacing your vp is a sign that
something is wrong
the the very news of replacing the vp if
trump were to do it
even if he takes pence and replaces him
with someone like equally okay
um that could be a wash but the news
that there's
chaos and disorganization with you know
were days before the convention at this
point the republican national convention
that could actually hurt donald trump
and
um there if we look at pence
specifically
you could also make the case that he's
complementary to trump in some way
i know that trump now pretends to be
religious and he says when he was in his
late 60s
he stopped being pro-choice and now he's
against abortion
and all of this you know he reads the
bible i don't believe any of it but to
the extent that anybody does or doesn't
believe it
mike pence's evangelical credentials
probably help
trump in some key states with the
evangelical base which um
again white evangelicals we'll talk
about this later actually white
evangelicals tend to vote republican
would they be turned off from trump if
pence wasn't there
i don't know so to me
a bad vp can really be a problem whereas
a good vp
just kind of keeps chugging along pence
in terms of demographics could actually
be good for trump
and a replacement itself could signal
trouble
and could backfire now the one thing i
am interested in that's that's maybe a
little bit
different this time around is we are
going to have
um a democratic female vp
candidate debating a white evangelical
older male republican in the vp debate
now if you think back to palin uh
uh versus biden back in 2008
uh sarah palin is just not
uh as as quick or or well-versed in
policy
or skilled at debating as is kamala
harris
but the dynamics were where you had
the democratic white male
debating against the younger republican
woman and that is a different dynamic
particularly in these times where
xenophobia is now welcomed into the open
by the presidency of donald trump the
the
racist right-wingers are more willing
than ever to say the things that they
were probably always thinking etc
i am interested in what the sort of
sidebar around the debate what is going
to be the right-wing coverage how are
they going to deal with kamala harris if
birther 2.0
is any sign the the early questions
about is kamal harris actually eligible
to be vp
um it could get very very ugly with a
woman of color on the democratic side
debating
evangelical white republican mike pence
that's in september uh actually no i
believe that the vp debate is not even
until october so we have some time
unless it gets cancelled but i think
that's going to be interesting but
should trump replace
pence probably not probably not